so I have here a very complicated
function it's got a two-dimensional
input to different coordinates to its
input and then a three-dimensional
output specifically it's a three
dimensional vector and each one of these
some expression that's bunch of cosines
and sines that depends on the two input
coordinates and in the last video we
talked about how to visualize functions
that have a single input a single
parameter like T and then a
two-dimensional vector output so some
kind of expression of T and another
expression of T and this is sort of the
three dimensional analog of that so what
we're going to do we're just going to
visualize things in the output space and
we're going to try to think of all the
possible points that could be outputs so
for example let's just start off simple
let's get a feel for this function by
evaluating it at a simple simple pair of
points so let's say we evaluate this
function f at T equals zero I think will
probably be pretty simple and then s is
equal to pi so let's think about what
this would be we go up when we say okay
T of 0 cosine of 0 is 1 so this whole
thing is going to be 1 same with this
one and sine of 0 is 0 so this over here
is going to be 0 and this is also going
to be 0 now cosine of PI is negative 1
so this here is going to be negative 1
this one here is also going to be
negative 1 and then sine of Pi
just like sine of 0 is 0 so this whole
thing actually ends up simplifying quite
a bit so that the top is 3 times 1 plus
negative 1
1 times negative 1 is negative 1 and we
get 2 then we have 3 times 0 plus 0 so
the Y component is just 0 and then the Z
component is also 0 so what that would
mean is that this output is going to be
the point that's 2 along the x axis and
there's nothing else to it it's just 2
along the x axis so go ahead and
well remove the graph about at that
point there so that's what would
correspond to this one particular input
zero and PI and you know you could do
this with a whole bunch and you might
add a couple other points based on other
inputs that you find but this will take
forever to start to get a feel of the
function as a whole and another thing
you can do is say okay maybe rather than
thinking of evaluating at a particular
point imagine one of the inputs was
constant so let's imagine that s stayed
constant at pi okay but then we let T
range freely so that means we're going
to have some kind of different different
output here and we're going to let T
just be some kind of variable while the
output is PI so what that means is we
keep all of these this negative one
negative one and zero for what sine of
pi is but the output now it's going to
be three cosine of T cosine of T plus
negative one times the cosine of T so
this can be minus cosine of T the next
part it's going to still be three sine
of T this is no longer zero I should
probably erase let's go those guys
actually so we're no longer evaluating I
won t was zero so three times sine of T
that's just still the function that
we're dealing with three sine of T and
then minus one times sine of T so minus
sine of T keep drawing it in green just
to be consistent and then the bottom
stays at zero and this whole thing
actually simplifies three cosine t minus
cosine T that's just two cosine T and
then same deal for the other one it's
going to be two sine of T so this whole
thing actually simplifies down
to this so this is again when we're
letting s stay constant and T ranges
freely and when you do that what you're
going to end up getting is a circle that
you draw on you can maybe see why it's a
circle because you have this cosine sine
pattern it's a circle with radius two
and it should make sense that it runs
through that first point that we
evaluated so that's what happens if you
let just one of the variables run but
now let's do the same thing but think
instead of what happens is s varies and
T stays constant I encourage you to work
it out for yourself I'll go ahead and
just kind of draw it because I kind of
want to give the intuition here so in
that case you're going to get a circle
that looks like this
so again I encourage you to try to think
through for the same reasons imagine
that you let s run freely keep T
constant at zero why is it that you
would get a circle that looks like this
and in fact if you if you let both T and
s run freely a very nice way to
visualize that is to imagine that this
circle which represents s running freely
sweeps throughout space as you start to
let T run freely and what you're going
to end up getting when you do that is
this shape that goes like this
and this is a doughnut we we have a
fancy word for this in mathematics we
call it a torus but it turns out the
function here is a fancy way of drawing
the torus and in another video I'm going
to go through in more detail if you're
just given the tourist how you could
find this function how you can kind of
get the intuitive feel for that and in
that it'll involve going through in a
bit more detail why when you sweep the
circle out it gets the torus just so and
what the relationship between the thread
circle and the blue circle is but here I
just kind of want to give an intuition
for what parametric surfaces are all
about how it's a way of visualizing
something that has a two a two
dimensional input and a three
dimensional output